what's the what is okay
all right here so I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing am I on a kid's show
what is this the elephant in the room
what's the elephant in the room well
that's what we're wondering if you have
any take on
well I think the elephant in the room is
Hollywood is making movies for the mob
on social media and not for General
audiences when you look at the successes
that have uh been the biggest films of
the year they've all been very
mainstream movies top gun Maverick being
among them right and I think that
there's a whole section of the audience
that has felt alienated by the infusion
of too much agenda
and really you know I go to the movies
to escape
I go to the movies to get involved in
someone's story and that story and that
person whose story that I'm experiencing
through their eyes may not even look
like me may not be the same gender as I
am may not be the same ethnicity I don't
care I want to be involved in a human
story that I can relate to and by relate
to I don't mean I need to see someone
who looks exactly like myself I think
that what needs to happen is is that the
the films that Hollywood makes should
really be reflective of the actual
audience
that goes to the movies we have seen
this year as we've
you know gotten past the before times so
to speak
the the lowest box office while we've
had box office hits
we have had far less tickets sold
in the United States
I mean most recently by the end of the
summer and going into the fall some of
the worst weekends we've ever seen now
there'll always be a number one movie at
the box office but when compared to
previous years
Hollywood has certainly not recovered I
think part of that is that the habit of
going to the movies has been lost
I think that these specialness of big
tentpole Hollywood movies has been
diminished by the sh by the the
shortened window you know hey it's in
the theaters uh I'll wait I'll wait and
I'll see it later on my 4K 75 inch TV
what is going to get audiences back to
the box office and it's telling stories
that are more Universal
and that means getting away from
lecturing and getting away from Identity
politics and really stop infusing agenda
into what should be Universal
storytelling
it's unfortunate because it used to be a
thing
where we'd all go to the movies and we'd
be talking about it the next week
right we would have discussions I liked
it I didn't like it my opinion about
that film is different than yours that's
fine I love love to disagree with people
about film my favorite conversations
I've ever had people I disagreed with
vehemently I love it it's the
conversation is the point it's not it's
not I'm not trying to be right okay
because we all have different
experiences we experience you know films
differently
so I'm still sitting here with this
elephant it's gonna
but I think really Hollywood needs to
get back to who is the core audience
how can we appeal to the most people but
in a way that doesn't seem pandering
and can there even be an American
identity I think this is kind of the
problem right now like we don't we we
disagree on so many so many issues
that I I think that's that's a difficult
task
so
um the way the challenges are out there
for Hollywood but uh just just get back
to the core entertaining people
and is the mob quote-unquote mob on
social media the new Focus Group
it's unfortunate that the mob on social
media is the focus group that's being
listened to I mean
focus groups can be useful right hey the
movie's 15 minutes too long we're
looking where where where can we find 15
minutes to cut out
you know
um I I think that the mob on social
media is very vocal but they're not your
core customer and Studios need to stop
listening to the Mob
that's that's the elephant in the room
stop listening to the Mob
listen to the elephant in the room
and we're not talking Good Fellas here
no yeah exactly stop listening to Social
Media mobs that go after people these
are people that are bored and generally
sad because they've got the time to
express uh whatever the horrific an
annoying opinion is
get away from it stay true make make a
and make a film that
that is going to move people
I really do think we're going to look
back on this era of filmmaking and think
how did so many bad movies get made
and I hope that I'm there to be able to
look back and go
why did they make that Pinocchio movie
with Tom Hanks and then someone's going
to say wait a sec they made a Pinocchio
live action movie with Tom Hanks oh my
God I saw it you're not going to believe
it it actually exists
I'm going to name 12 Movies 12 woke
movies okay quote unquote and I'd love
to hear your reaction sure so first one
Thelma and Louise Thelma and Louise
could be considered woke
having said that I I don't consider that
movie uh in in the sense of how we see
woke today because I I don't feel it's
it's it doesn't lecture
I don't feel like I'm being lectured to
in that film but yeah that that has I
would say that it definitely has
Progressive messages but I wouldn't even
really necessarily put that in a woke
category
for me personally I think there's a
different way that messages have been
infused into Hollywood
in the past and it's very different now
where the messaging is right on the nose
and you're being told you're a bad
person if you don't actually like the
movie like if you don't like this if you
don't like this movie you're racist or
if you don't like this movie you're a
sexist or how could you not like this
movie because this person made it
um I kind of call BS on that
so and I don't necessarily consider it's
certainly a feminist film
for sure
you know
I don't have a problem with it do the
right thing
get out
Fruitvale Station
Mad Max Fury Road Straight Out of
Compton All About Eve Mean Girls
Philadelphia Remember the Titans glory
and hidden figures
I don't know that I would call those all
woke films there's certainly movies that
I'll have messages right and and look
Hollywood films have always been filled
with messages I think what's new today
is that the messaging is infused in a
more overt way it used to be underneath
the surface the messages used to be the
subtext of the film
you know
for example uh you know
just like Dances with Wolves right has a
lot of messages in it but it's but it's
it's
it's just right there I think that a lot
of films that are coming out now and the
reason people are reacting so poorly is
that audiences are being judged based on
if they like a movie or not
you're you're free to not like Thelma
and Louise you're free to not like do
the right thing you're free to not like
those films that's perfectly fine
but it doesn't make but what I think is
interesting is they're trying to make
people out to be bad
for having a different opinion about a
movie
I've never seen this in my life and I
think that's that's kind of
I think that's what's turned a lot of
people off to a movie they may actually
enjoy but refuse to see
um there's a recent example of that the
movie The Woman King
which I think the woman King was
completely misrepresented in its
marketing it was marketed to be one
thing and then the movie is is something
something else there's much more to the
film
and
I've never seen this happen
in a time that I've been around where an
audience is being accused of being
sexist or racist for not liking a film
or a particular filmmaker you're free to
not like those things
and the fact that people feel like they
have to go along with sort of the the
the what they think is the majority of
people in their peer group
well everyone thinks this so I'm gonna
I'm gonna also think that
and I I just find that kind of
weak-minded I always like people who
have uh different opinions
about about films
but I it's unbelievable to me that that
people
's opinion can can vilify them or make
people look differently how could you
not like this how could you not not like
this this particular film or filmmaker
never seen that ever before and I and I
find it kind of shocking
what I think is most disheartening is
when you see like a studio kind of use
it almost like a marketing strategy
you know this was this was done with
Amazon and the rings of power they tried
to accuse audiences of being racist for
not liking
the diverse cast
and
there's quite a crossover audience
between fans of
Lord of the Rings
and Game of Thrones
and so HBO comes out with House of the
Dragon well that's also a diverse cast
and people love that show so what is it
the same fans who were accused of being
racist for not liking uh the character
of Riva in the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
were also the same fans
who begged to please please
put Lando Calrissian in a Star Wars
movie
same fans
please please can you put Mace Windu
played by Samuel L Jackson please put
him in the Kenobi series
you can't accuse these fans of of of
those kinds of things I think it's it's
really disingenuous on the Studio's
parts and I think what they're doing is
is that they're sort of shielding
themselves from criticism
by making certain creative choices
and the fans can can like it or not like
it whatever
but I don't think they're they're racist
for not liking a particular film or
character you know some characters
resonate Lando Calrissian is a badass
love him
people love the character of Mace Windu
and what's weird is
um
so many so many today think like well
this is this is the first time we've
ever had a character
of color in in a film when you look back
in particular genre Science Fiction and
Fantasy has had diverse casts from the
beginning you know back in the 70s
so this is this is not new what's new is
using it as a piece of marketing and
weaponizing IT against audiences to me
it's always a losing strategy
it's always a losing strategy to do that
let the work speak for itself if people
don't like it don't vilify your audience